[Musique]
vous estimez être un bon père j'espère
maintenant ce sera maisons font de
répondre plus tard mais en tout cas je
suis un ami ducation que ça le temps
vous avez reçu je crois que c'est plus
cool quand même un ouais c'est ça même
trop c'est le seul nom jg je les vois
grandir mais je me dis j'espère qu'ils
seront pas aussi dur que moi je l'aider
vous êtes un groupe de citoyens ont voté
pas alors bah non c'est vrai que je vote
pas je vous passe maintenant alors je
vais vous dire si si c'est franchement
je m'en veux mais j'ai un problème c'est
que je suis tellement fénéon pour les
papiers savoir je vous jure c'est vrai
assistance à la mairie tout ça voilà ces
mêmes mais tout cela doit vous me
connaissez pas cap read demandé à non
mais moi juste allé à la mairie faire un
papier monter tout ça je me connais je
sais je suis une catastrophe là dedans
on installe vous devait pas parler de la
société bah oui non mais c'est vrai ces
réseaux n'est pas citoyen paris non mais
ça je m'en veux vous donner ma voix
prochaine ce prochaine prochaine
présidentielle j'aurai ma carte
d'électeur ou cinq à dix ans à 1 0 peut
être ça quelque chose vous voulez je le
fasse pour vous oui c'est un très bon et
bien je vous enverrai une photo avec ma
carte d'électeur ouais je suis très très
bien voilà on va le faire elle vous êtes
un patron droite ont un patron gauche à
je suis il faut leur demander mais je
pense que je suis le problème c'est que
c'est plus sain qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence entre un patron de boîte un
patron de gauche déjà
est-ce que vous avez cessé d'en mettre
plein les poches quand vous tentez de
distribuer avec mes salariés problème
c'est que je leur cède tout
c'est ça c'est que vraiment on est
vraiment sur cette touche eric moi j'ai
des gens qui travaillent avec moi tous
les jours j'ai des appels cyril tu peux
pas leur dire oui mais ça va à l'essai
et on verra je vois là je sais pas dire
non c'est le problème que j'ai j'ai dit
oui à tout le monde donc ça c'est un
gros souci tout
autant les intermittents
[Musique]